on continue à parler musique tout à fait
avec donc Camilla bayibé bonsoirons euh
donc vous représentez ce soir donc le
scarabé tout à fait et vous aussi vous
avez une programmation riche des
vendredis puisque vous mettez en place
pour la première fois cette année un
trempelin de la chanson euh chanson
français chanson à texte alors
expliquez-nous le principe oui alors
effectivement c'est une grande première
pour nous on s'est au niveau de la
programmation spécialisé depuis quelques
années dans la chanson et notre adhésion
au cri qui est un centre de ressources
Linois pour la musique cent ressour qui
est un réseau départemental qui
coordonne plusieurs salles don le café
de la plage mon collègue d'à côté euh
sur le les musiques actuelles et on
s'est dit qu'on allait voilà tenter
quelque chose autour de la chanson au
niveau du département donc c'est un
trempelin qui est ouvert au groupe
amateur et semi-professionnels du
département d'accord donc il aura trois
dates ça TR soirées trois soirées trois
concerts trois soirées de concert avec
plusieurs groupes à chaque fois ex trois
groupes sur chaque soir et chaque groupe
donc va être mise en concurrence les uns
les autres donc vous avez constitué un
jury c'est ça exactement alors on a à la
fois un jury professionnel on va dire
qui est constitué de Neu personnes donc
il y a des représentant du scarabé
Samuel Denis qui est le directeur et qui
est chargé de la programmation moi-même
au niveau de l'action culturelle et mon
collègue régisseur Christophe et on a
également donc notre élu à la culture
Michel jardin la directrice de servicees
à la population de la ver
deux artistes la verrière donc Vincent
Lichti et Ivan dotin et un jeune
associatif qui uvre pour la musique
sappelle kalalistooun et son association
lisayan musique et le directeur de
l'école de musique voilà je crois j'ai
fait le tour c'est un très très large
avec différentes c'est très alors c'est
très voilà très axé sur la verrière pour
cette première édition en tout cas mais
c'est des sensibilités différentes des
générations aussi différent pour avoir
voilà une palette assez large et donc le
le le prix ENIT en fait enfin la
répartition euh parce que le public peut
aussi voter exactement il a
particularité donc votre jury constitué
là de de de de vos membres verrièroi on
vous appeler comme ça en partie pour
2/ers de voilà et un/ers pour le public
mais alors le public pour voter euh
tapez vous tapez de vous envoyez un SMS
pas téléphone portable comment font-il à
larière il y a un petit bulletin de vote
qui va être remis aux spectateurs lors
de la première soirée et lors de la
première soirée uniquement puisque
l'idée c'est pas d'avoir un gagnant par
soir mais trois gagnants au terme des
trois soirées euh donc le public qui
vote c'est celui qui a vu tous les
spectacles qui sera là au trois soirées
voilà donc la contraint c'est d'être
présent quand même au trois dates
exactement pour pouvoir bien juger alors
pour donner un aperçu des groupes qui
qui vont se présenter euh on va regarder
un extrait donc c'est une compilation
des trois groupes qui sont en
représentation donc vendre soir on
regarde on se content de peu c'était
déjà beaucoup un pour de dans les jours
un peu fous on n jamais souhaité la vie
à 5 étoile qu' demand un confort
banal
petit joger dans la brume du matin fait
son footing ignore les bouche du
Métropolitain dans son jogging s'il
croque tant de kilomètres c'est pour s
Bour les super
flast que danses jolis
basketsil moi
jouflu dans la lumière c'est ma chambre
maintenant tu min mon petitamour en musi
qui préère
spécialiste tuis
en trois groupes qui sont en compétition
sur ce rendez-vous du scarabé le
vendredi vous l'avez dit on peut
rementionner les trois groupes les trois
artistes les uns des autres j'agace
ériic et les affanchi voilà et le public
va devoir choisir voter en plus de votre
jury et oui et alors donc vous avez reçu
un certain nombre de candidatures 31
ouais et vous avez dû faire une
sélection pour en retenir donc neuf
trois par soir quels étaient vos
critères alors de sélection alors il y
avait des critères très objectifs qui
était le lieu de résidence des des
membres du groupe puisque l'idée c'était
uniquement de travaill sur le
département euh et puis des choses on va
dire un peu plus subjectifes sur euh la
dénomination chanson alors c'est vrai
que c'est c'est pas une catégorie très
strictement défini pour nous l'important
c'était que le texte a une place
particulière au sein de de des créations
proposées que ce soit en français ce
qu'on appelle donc des des chansons à
texte oui voilà et majoritairement enfin
que le plus gros de de de de leur
production soit en français oui c'était
aussi un élément important d'accord et
et puis voilà après on a écouter
réécouter mis des notes discuter pour
évaluer les les groupes mieux et en
sélectionner neuf et le public qui va
devoir se prononcer on gagne quoi alors
et ben oui qu'est-ce que vont gagner C
ces trois lauréat alors il y a des prix
à gagner monétaire on va dire qui sont
des des petits coups de pouce pour
réaliser des choses des de matériels des
enregistrements enfin voilà l'idée c'est
que les groupes s'en servent en fonction
de de leurs besoins donc c'est pour ça
on leur donne une enveloppe et ils en
font font ce qu' ce qu'ils veulent pour
se développer au mieux et aujourd'hui
est-ce que avec le le retour
d'expérience que vous avez est-ce qu'il
y a des groupes ou des artistes qui sont
passés par le scarabé et qui ont été
révélés grâce à vous alors révélé grâce
à nous ça c'est un grand mot mais c'est
vrai qu'il arrive en écumant les
festivals comme ça qu'on qu'on est un
coup de cœur pour un artiste qui n'est
pas encore connu du grand public qu'on
décide de le programmer et puis que la
notoriété Vienne petit à petit ça a été
le cas pour pour Anaïs par exemple ou
pour Ben l'onclle sou qui est voilà qui
a
explosé peu de temps après voilà donc
c'est c'est des chos
qui
exactement alors donc la première soirée
c'est vendredi à partir de 20h30 ensuite
la seconde date c'est le 26 avrililà 2
17 mai tris dates pour donc participer à
ce rendez-vous merci à vous merci
également café de la plage avec ce
rendez-vous choliver a on fait juste une
petite pose avant d'accueillir un groupe
le beau à brassbande c'est bien ça cette
fanfare qui va venir sur ce plateau dans
un instant une posusetinée pour
l'instant vos avis sur les derniers
films à l'affiche depuis ce matin comme
chaque mercredi un micro trottoir signé
elodim moine très bon film très
dynamique Franck Dubosque toujours
formidable parfait un film distrayant
pour toute la famille c bien parce que
le chien il faisait plein de bêtises et
il était amoureux de la Tortue dans la
maison quand ça a commencé il avait fait
bêtis les dit dans une cage c'était bien
il y a plein d'action c'est c'est
marrant les musiques elles
étaient bien tout était bien quoi c'est
un film d'espionnage donc avec Jean du
jardin et Cécile de France non non j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt sympa c'est la
complexité des des affaires sur fond de
financeces de magouille et de
d'espionnage quoi bon un petit James
Bond quoi c'est un film extraordinaire
avec une densité
et surtout une délicatesse voilà j'ai
beaucoup aimé parce que je connaissais
pas cette ce weekend entre le roi
d'Angleterre et Franklin Roosevelt je
savais pas qu' s'était rencontré donc
c'était puis c'est un bon film c'est
bien joué c'est il y a de l'humour c'est
c'est agréable c'est agréable c'est bien
joué c'est plein de bonne humeur pour
une période qui est pas facile et puis
surtout ce qui est bien c'est le choc
des cultures on s'amuse beaucoup et
il y a toute une histoire autour mais je
vous dirai pas parce qu'il faut voir
mais franchement on s'amuse beaucoup
c'est joli il y a des paysages
magnifiques les acteurs sont excellent
non vraiment allez-y allez-y c'est très
bien